[Applaudissements]
thor c'est parti je regardais je vais
faire je vais tenter un truc avec la
région alors restez là c'était bien à
une bonne piste et les gars vous savez
ce qu'il ne savait pas ce qui se passe
que je dis tout espère pardon s'il vous
plaît merci
en fait là en régie sans déconner ils
sont comme les chaussures google à
mylène farmer libera liberté on l'est où
les gars en régie
ah ah
henri giraud régime ne fait plus rien
tant rester tranquilles ou rester
tranquille buvait des verts a des trucs
ne fait plus rien ce qu'on l'a cet hymne
à faire là bas est recalé restez bien
assis
si vous n'avez rien à faire ce soir on
va recaler cette image regardez regardez
et là on n'a pas le son vous souhaite un
bon joueur mais par an merci c'est bon
c'est fait merci à toi je ferai
attention à ne plus recommander de
recaler les images mais je suis tomber
dans leur piège
j'ai voulu faire confiance à l'équipe en
régie j'étais en confiance que depuis
quelques jours ça marche bien et la
voilà mais patatras